lots of consensus it's mostly going to
be about the doctor called underlying
the Bitcoin blockchain introduced by to
confuse things a little bit I'm gonna
use similar terminology that Elaine used
but to mean different things so let me
let me start by recalling some of it so
when I say consensus I'm gonna mean the
same task as which he meant with
consensus but when I say block share I'm
gonna mean something else and Elaine
already hinted at later on so for now
consensus is what people in distributed
systems have studied for a long time
under name state machine replication so
when I say consensus that's what I mean
so what is this task this is what the
Lane introduced let me just do it again
so make sure we're on the same page so
we had a fixed set of nodes these guys
would like to agree on an ever-growing
log of transactions so like in this
example this is Google and they would
like to have a list of transactions in
Google Wallet and they would like to
replicate this whole database of
transactions among these nodes and the
nodes need to agree on what these
transactions are this is what we refer
to as consistency and the second
property is liveness is that whenever
some node sees some transaction that
should be added to this database to this
ledger then this transaction should be
added sufficiently fast
and so you want these two puppies hold
under some conditions such as 2/3 or all
but one being faulty and we'll see very
different very different assumptions
under which this can be achieved and
Alain discussed several of them before
so as you heard this creature today has
many different names when people say
permission blockchain this is actually
what they mean also and that's maybe
more the more hip name of state machine
occasion but really this has been around
for forever at least since their first
permission is that we have seven nodes
that you need a permission to enter
everybody knows who is allowed to be
there that's what a permission
blockchain is okay but really permission
box is the same thing a state machine
application as defined by French Snyder
in the 80s or something or a public
ledger same thing but I will use mostly
name State with your application or
consensus so let's recall these two
properties of consistency liveness again
so consistency says the following take
any two nodes at any given point to this
execution
so me and Mohammad we look at the logs
that we have and we should agree at any
given point we should agree what does it
mean to agree what potentially has seen
a transaction I haven't seen so either
and that's fine right because some
transaction came to you first you hasn't
propagated over network yet but what we
mean by agreement is that either my list
is a prefix of his or vice-versa it
turns out that actually just consistency
between any two players is not enough
you need to let be a little bit be
careful in how you define this and you
also need this other thing which today
is called future sub consistency that I
need to be consistent not only with
everybody else at any given point but
also my future self the consistency says
taken in two guys we agree at the
recurring point and also what I have
today
agrees with what I will have
future and liveness this you heard about
this morning and it was discussed quite
a bit so it just says that there exists
some fixed polynomial t that says how
long it takes for a transaction to be
confirmed
so whenever some node it receives a
transaction as input and would like to
get it added that transaction should be
added so everybody's letter within t
steps and this t could actually be
parametrized by the the maximal network
delay so we have some parameter delta
that determines the maximum delay it
takes for a message to get propagated on
the network and of course if it takes a
long time I cannot hope it's to arrive
at everybody first so it needs to be a
function of this network delay as you
also heard this morning there are two
main models in which this type of
consensus protocol have been studied the
first one is the the cleanest and
simplest synchronous model this model we
have this maximum network delay and the
protocol can be parameterize to it so
the easiest way to think about it is
that protocol proceeding rounds and
every round you wait two Delta steps
let's say to make sure that you received
all the messages for sure and under the
moment a next round
and you send your message away to Delta
or something like that so that's the
synchronous model these particles are
loved and also hated because they take a
long time because you have to wait to
this maximum network delay which is
annoying so there is nice C type of
protocols called partial synchronous
protocols where the same protocol should
work for any data so reportable unaware
of a delta is and so my protocol is not
parameterize by this thing it kind of
usually precedes very very fast and
typically when Delta is small you will
go fast when Delta is long it will go
slow okay because it's unaware of what
deltas
different so yes that's what I'm saying
are you slightly different so the
original paper on defining parts of
synchrony by dwara clinch and stockmeyer
this was the main way to defined it then
they defined a slightly different weight
which was a GST the way Elaine use that
typically these models are the same
because of some doubling trick but this
is kind of a simply we explain a lot
okay so just to make sure we understand
what these two properties imply and why
we like them so much the point is if you
have a protocol for Ford running this
type of consensus that satisfies
consistency of liveness that means in
essence this protocol implements a
trusted public ledger so think of it as
having a trusted third party to which
you give transactions whenever somebody
wants they can send him a transaction he
is make sure to add it within T of Delta
time and then anybody can come and look
at you can ask the trusted third party
and the third subvert third party will
give you a prefix of what he has stored
up to something close to Delta doesn't
make sense so really this is very nice
because you can really think of it as
having some stone where people are
writing transactions into it and people
can observe this stone we might not see
exactly the same thing but we're very
close right maybe there is a some gap in
what we see but it's only going to be
based on something small based on Delta
okay so quickly recalling what's how
this classic traditional model proceeds
and some key features of it and that's
why it's actually today called the
permission setting so what makes it
permission
well the key thing is that the number of
players n in race talk is fixed and
everybody knows it just like we do a
normal crypto we received the number of
players at that's an input or protocol
right we know it not only we know how
many people are there we also know their
names I need to know who I'm talking to
it's all of us talking we know who we
are okay this is common knowledge
actually classically we focused on
selling we're notes stick around if you
want to be part of this protocol you're
there from day one and you're there
until the evening when it's time to go
home asleep okay there's no breaks you
come you work and then you go home the
third thing which is actually
potentially the most important one is we
assume that we're communicating in a way
that allows you to authenticate
ourselves to one another okay and there
are two models typically considered
either authenticated channels which is
just we have some channels to one
another the point-to-point madlyn
mentioned where when I send a message to
Mohammed he knows it comes from me
another model which is a stronger model
is this PKI model where we assume that
we additionally add some setup have some
summary providing us with some public
keys and secret keys and and and the set
of public case is actually commonly
known also to different models in fact
so these two different models as you
heard this morning give rise to
different type of results okay so
particularly summarizing the
state-of-the-art or not well this is all
stuff from the 80s right the main
results here are we really understand
exactly what's going on right if you
don't care about efficiency in run
complexity in terms of philosophies
ability things are very well understood
in a synchronous model remember now the
protocol is parameterize by Delta then
Jake's are possible with authenticated
channels if two-thirds honest and
they're impossible and you saw the
impossibility results if less than
two-thirds or less okay so you can do
something without a PGI if two-thirds
honest and if you edition of the PGI
then this beautiful dollar stroll
protocol works no matter how many people
corrupt it if there is a difference
between authenticate Charles a PK you
can do better in the PK model in
addition have money functions and that's
that a 2/3 without the key is the best
you can do and the partial think
resetting things are harder in fact 2/3
you can still do it but here a peak here
doesn't help and 2/3 is just the best
you can hope for
ok so this is what you should remember
from the classic setting 2/3 it's
possible even with partial synchrony no
need for PGI but in the synchronous
model if you have picker you can handle
any number of corruptions and then the
partial sync recipe care doesn't help
it's a very simple argument reduces it's
picky I thought strong has a PPI doesn't
it doesn't in this but on a strong is
not in the partially synchronous model
the last one assumes synchrony very
important don't live in strong yes
reduces Byzantine into face stop and
face stop we can do punch on sync on ok
let me give you let me give it a
possibility result ok so you have how is
it so you have two guys
no take three three of course but we
have two guys here these guys are
talking very fast to exhibit it takes me
there are three players right these two
guys are talking very fast to one
another and so yeah so this guy is going
to either you can talk to each other so
the two first guys are these two guys
are slow
[Music]
I know that bring with you - yeah so
this the complete you are descended we
shouldn't
let's let's take this offline the point
is there is a simply possibility which I
don't know I'm blanking on it but
explain after I have one more question
yet in the synchronous network model
like the I thought over the the rule of
thumb is that you have you can make
synchronous to one half so in this model
we're dealing with consensus this is the
same question as a neighbor just this
morning yeah right now all the nodes are
being present there okay in that case in
a synchronous model you can do dollar
strong and do rotating guys you can
handle em s1 corruption it's not
publicly verifiable it's not there isn't
this is look in this thing we have this
only these guys are participating and I
only want consensus among these guys
there are no outside people only these
guys need to agree this is what you want
when you want to have a data base and
distribute away only nodes are
participating should agree I don't care
about any outsiders vodcast but it can
easily turn it in some networks like
this but just rotating leaders first the
first guy goes he sends something that
was strong then setting I goes and so on
support so first I go then Mohammad goes
and he tie goes and everybody sends
their the transaction will broadcast
using the lustrum that's a way to get
and all the listed transactions
oh yeah that's different yeah so now I'm
talking about state machine application
among these notes this is the definition
it can be done and - one model is every
that you have recently for now let's
assume that we have someone is to
generate a public keys and secret keys
there are many different usually these
results like dollar strong actually work
in a week was cryptographers called the
public key model but for our simplicity
there's no I'm just saying you need
digital signatures
I want a digital signature yes the
implication is not in the PKI model you
need digital signatures you can actually
sometimes get a get away with
information theoretic things also if you
want for abundant number of times you
have these transferrable things - just
more annoying but I will just try to
simplify things here ok so what I'm
going to talk about today is this
different setting which is what Nakamoto
is him okay and that's this
permissionless setting so the
permissionless setting was kind of
introduced in nakamoto's paper from 2009
and the idea was to to be able to run
this top consensus protocols among
anybody who wants to join okay that's
why it's permissionless there is no need
to have a permission to join you don't
have to be one of the servers at google
anybody can be part of a stick and in
the first block he had this text about
charles lonely brink of second payload
for banks he was clearly motivated by
the fact that the might be this flashy
crisis and the banks are not to be
trusted and they could screw the users
of the money right so they wanted to
have a system where the banks are not in
control of over m'yha of our money
so what I will try to do today is try to
discuss some of the key features of this
permissionless model and how it differs
from the permission model really all of
the three properties that I stated
before are now gone and we like to
handle this kind of a lot more
adversarial scenario so first thing is
we don't know how many other notes are
out there but anybody should be able to
Joe so we I don't know how many people
are there okay remember before we knew
exactly how many there were and who you
are
second of all this thing at notes can
come and go misses also referred to us
late joining this one perhaps is not so
new that has been around actually before
but it's became more relevant now and
then the third thing which as I
mentioned was perhaps the most pertinent
feature is there are no authentication
mechanism right there is no
pre-established pci and we don't assume
that the existence of authenticate
channels we're just talking to people I
don't know who they are
then finally here's a kind of nun today
not a mathematical property but it's
some kind of like desiderata that we'd
like to get this protocol sister running
among everybody would like to get some
kind of economical game theoretic
robustness okay this is kind of vague
and yeah I would like to focus on more
they're kind of distributed computing
problem it's just as a normal computer
science problem so I'm going today skip
this thing for now and get back to it
later on because this is kind of not
exactly clear to define so I'm gonna
just focus on these things and these are
very well defined mathematical ways of
modifying the classic model so as you
see this is a much more chatting setting
right we letting go of assumptions we're
sharing them one by one and so now the
question is what can we do and we really
are I would argue still in just the
beginning of understanding this model
it's quite different so let's start off
by just focusing on this thing which as
I mentioned wasn't perhaps the most
important feature that we don't have any
authentication mechanisms and let's see
what happens when you really remove
authentication from the classic setting
in fact this thing was a model that we
considered together with run
collectivist you now both Baraka nettie
Linda and Robin in 2005
so we said we'd like to design
cryptographic protocols in a setting
where we don't have a tentacle channels
and what can be done and the first kind
of observation already intro is actually
can't do anything okay so we were
looking at a scenario which was in a
partially synchronous model and there is
actually a trivial impossibility of
consensus without authenticated channels
in a portion of synchros network so let
me just very quickly show it if I
remember it so we have say we have some
some set of notes here lots of notes yet
I'd like to agree on something and here
is a final guy that actually should be
should have been there talking to them
what I'll do is I'll put him out well
actually not let him talk to all the
others and then I'm going to here
emulate all the others for him right now
this guy the way he sees the world is
he's talking to this simulation that I'm
performing for him okay this is kind of
the nightmare you might have that you
wake up and you're just living in a
simulation well these people are so nice
to there are actually a lot of the
really ones developed actually abducted
by an alien and they're just doing it to
do some kind of like you're whining to
extract that stiff stuff from your brain
all right so this is what happens to
this guy he's here now he's talking to
this simulation and so so this guy's are
now running in the protocol with let's
say they're putting in some transaction
a B and C and since this protocol is
secure they should output this protocol
say this transactions ABC
now this guy what does he see well he's
talking to these guys and maybe here I'm
running it with some X Y & Z so now he
should be outputting X Y Z instead so
now we have broken consistency so by
lightness
these guys will add privacy and this guy
by lightness will output X Y Z and
therefore we broken consistency because
they are put different things so I'm
just separating this thing and it can be
done
note here that one very important part
of it that this guy doesn't see this
message is coming from this guy's right
and that is possible because I can
actually these messages they want to
send things to him also okay they might
be flooding Internet where say please
send this to Sandra but I can actually
all this message that they want to send
to this thing that maybe or is it
flooded or network I'm gonna delay them
and I can delay them for very long if a
protocol partial synchronous these guys
need to provide an output even after
it's been delayed then the authenticate
channels come here with this delays with
so
you said without authentication this
attack is possible but then like that
mean we don't enter conditions I cannot
simulate these messages okay so this is
like so right now what I'm doing I'm
doing this I need to be able to do this
kind of costly simulation where I can
simulate everybody else in the world we
don't have to catch it you can still
separate the node out of the network
right like a separate another network
yeah and he doesn't but that's okay
because he doesn't need to provide an
output until and until the message comes
okay yes so right now this was like the
only one from what we heard this was a a
simple observation but we took it out
saying like this is this model is kind
of it's an interesting model not
considered authentication but we said we
can never hope to get consistency so
what we did in that paper was even
started considering a model where you
can do secure computation without
consistency okay so we said like look I
can never hope to prevent this thing but
we can consider some model where at
least this execution should be
independent of one another and and that
turns out to be actually even that is
non-trivial to do but so we give up on
consistency and I'm dealt with an ocean
security where you can define other
security purposes but just giving up a
consistency all right so where the
synchronous thing turns out to be a
little bit trickier okay and so the
problem here is that this guy might now
hear this message is also so now he's
getting confused right he will hear what
I'm doing XYZ but he will also hear this
a B and C messages so he will output XYZ
he will also up with a B and C okay
potentially right I'm not sure what this
particle does but it was nothing that
prevents him from also being able you
see I'm getting this conflict anything
but made the protocol tell him they're
like you know what I hear too many
things let me just play or both and
output everything so
so this doesn't quite work and likewise
he could start sending these messages to
these other guys and they will also put
X Y Z yeah okay but there is actually a
way to modify it and this is based on
this old impossibility results from the
classic distributed consensus literature
in particular this impossibility result
by Fisher Lynch Merritt was at the right
time so so if I remember it so let's say
we have hundred people out there and
let's split them into two groups so we
have 50 of them 15 we'll call this with
all these guys
and this is cute I'd mention call this
guy historic you stop so just bundling
them together okay and there's a bunch
of messages being sent between them and
as much as being sent between P and Q
and these guys I'm going to start
running them on some very sample some
transaction has a random number let's
say let's call it takes T zero so this
is a random number and a bit long string
okay and now so these are the two on
this case they should be running without
one another and if I run this protocol
obviously they should output this
transaction right now I'm gonna also
create some noise for them how will I do
that well I'm gonna simulate here to him
some cue I think I'm gonna run it on
some dummy input okay and there's some
some other noise here so P dummy and I'm
gonna do this very long circle very very
very long until I get to some other P
here and cuter okay let me call them
till there
and all these guys are running on dummy
and this guy I'm gonna run on some other
transaction t1 that's also RAM these
silly okay let's make sense so these two
honest guys are running as usual but
right now I'm also pretending to be the
cute guys to him so now here's double
noise right to here is there the real
thing
and here's other messages therapy
pretending to come from them
he doesn't know which one is the right
one but as we said before he might be
able to maybe output both so let me
argue that we'll have to get to some
contradiction here so we said that these
two guys to get output e0 right
initially
what I would argue is that any two
consecutive guys they're gonna output
either t0 first or t1 first so they need
to have a log of transactions right
everybody has a logger transaction
regarding so either t0 is above or t1 is
above right by symmetry let's assume
that t0 is about t1 or maybe t1 doesn't
appear at all at all so let's assume
here that t0 is output these two guys by
consistency Nita put the signal first
right therefore these two guys by
consistency also need output t0 first
right because these two guys are just
like two on the skies these are just and
it's people acting exactly as the noting
cue people acting exactly as a note
think you know everybody you make this
long link that people don't talk to each
other and I thought that this is the
problem here I'm saying that the I am
doing the links right this guy's talking
this this guy's talking to that right
this is just in my head the way this
these two guys view it
they have only access to they talk to
they get messages from him and they get
messages from from this guy this is all
reality right the way around attack is
like these two guys Adonis two guys and
then there's some noise I'm giving them
okay so what I'm marking is like in my
emulation my head these two guys need
tools output the same thing this one is
to come first so t0 needs to come first
here - okay so - zero comes first before
t1 and so on so forth and by consistency
everybody needs to output t0 first
okay now how fast should i output to
zero
well sometimes depends on Delta okay
it was this big t of Delta let's say
it's within a thousand steps okay now if
this ring that I'm just doing in my head
it's very very big much bigger than
thousand that there is no way that this
t zero could have propagated down to
here because he gets a message from here
after the first step maybe this guy
learned so T 0 is but he will only in
that case we were to tell this guy after
two steps and so on and so forth so you
can now be just say that you know in
this after T steps only people up to
their T steps away from this guy could
have ever heard about T zero information
theoretically and therefore there's no
way that this guy could've output T zero
okay so the point is without
authentication
we're doomed
yeah this is where like a motor comes in
because he says that we're not doomed
without authentication we can do it
anyways so so how does he do it the
whole point here was that when we did
all these arguments it required us to be
able to simulate lots of other players
in our head and like a motor would like
to us to be able to prevent this type of
simulation arguments in our heads and
how can we do it by requiring people to
work hard to participate in protocol and
that makes it impossible to do this type
of Sibyl attacks when I'm submitting
lots of players because simulating lots
of prayers requires a lot of
computational resources
that alone is not good enough to just
use the proof-of-work doesn't overcome
these lower bounds right we also need to
change the model somehow and the way it
changes the model is to say I'm not
going to say that a certain fraction of
the players are honest because fractions
of players doesn't mean anything in the
setting because we can do this I can
simulate anybody I want so instead I'm
gonna make the assumption that a
majority of the computing power in the
world is held by honest players so I'm
gonna have a protocol that's
computational intensive to run and then
make the assumption that the majority of
the computing power is honest and then
under these two things he claims that he
got something actually satisfies this
kind of state machine replication
satisfying consistency in lightness
that's very nice
so let me point out the two really
amazing aspect of this thing really
worthwhile well the first one is the two
overcomes is an authentication problem
that's really what he wanted to do but
not something else he claimed that it
was secure under just an honest majority
there was no PK in the setting this also
overcomes this one third barrier that we
saw from Alain stock somehow it's
actually very insightful to look at
exactly how that previous impossibility
breaks down because that was a very
common impossibility right what happens
here in this authenticated setting well
not here that in this argument at the
line did that hacker even when I was
meant to get Chagas needed to simulate
these three other players not just
himself but actually needs to do for
people instead so right now if all of
them were spending computation resources
he's actually spending a lot of
computational resources right as
actually spending four times more than
an honest guy
so the number computed like the amount
of computation research is spending is
way more than honest people so it
doesn't overcome nakamoto's but it's not
only honest majority in terms of
computational resources
okay so the point here is that by
switching this perspective to
compounding computational resources and
by having protocols are computationally
expensive we can actually potentially
overcome this these barriers with
dealing with without authentication and
also getting above this one third
barrier and getting to to one half so
for the rest of this these two hours
much less time left and I would have a
hope for what I'm trying to go over is
first kind of an abstract notion of a
blockchain so explain what the
blockchain protocol is and then define
some kind of abstraction that is a
little bit more refined than just state
machine replication and it's a result
that's actually useful to have an
abstract notion of blockchain that's not
just a place your application and I'll
explain why and then we'll discuss where
the neck and motifs protocol actually
works and originally there was a little
bit of confusion in whether it works or
not so in the original part not Nakamoto
he showed that certain classes of a very
natural type of attack that the analyzed
doesn't work but of course that's just
one attack and they could have been many
others and there were many subsequent
were a few different subsequent works
most notably this is very beautiful work
by Geritol that really started off by
having a very formal way of analyzing
this protocol that showed that large
classes of attacks don't work then at
the same time the world is kind of
attacks on it and in particular was a
claimed attack showing that by making
use of the fact that all Network delays
particular assumed enter ten-second
network delays the network they claimed
49.1% attack so attacker that only has
49.1% could break the protocol okay so
maybe you don't reach exactly 50 but
it's kind of okay at this point is not
clear what answer is - we know will this
attack be improved or
or can we show this girl tight and so it
turns out that right now we have good
techniques for our game that actually as
long as you set the parameters through
protocol correctly it is secure but
let's start by by discussing what what a
blockchain is and how this marching
protocol works what number we'll get to
it later okay
turns out that that number actually they
had a calculation mistake so it should
have been actually 49 points AI all see
what it is for 9.8 I think or something
Oh get it all right so what is it
blockchain yeah this is what a
blockchain is this is the abstract
notion of lock chain you have a bunch of
blocks of a chain now you know a little
bit more concretely let me start off
with the nakamoto's original protocol
and most we probably have seen this
protocol but let me do it anyway slowly
just to make sure we're on the same page
so we'd like to change together blocks
of transactions and let me show how to
do it kind of inductively so let's say
that we have already generated some kind
of chain of transactions and how should
we add some more transactions into this
chain so let's say that Ellie would like
to give Alessandro 50 bitcoins okay and
this is one of these transactions that's
bundled together into a block just a
funny story here like when I first gave
this talk this was roughly a bike okay a
nice bike but slab bike and today it's a
nice house in Berkeley that took from
Zillow this morning so I looked on
Zillow this is from this morning this
house you can look it up yourself
no this is this I updated you see the
slides on this part of it or you don't
actually yes this is like instead of
doing these slides I should have bought
instead of this bikes that anybody got
stolen later on you know it's a house in
Berkeley okay so we have this set of
transactions we bundle and to get
interblock and now the protocol like
about this protocol is extremely simple
this is what it does it does everybody
wants a participate now anybody can be
here participate they will take this new
block they look at the end of the chain
up until this point
and they put the end of the chain which
is that the hash of the current chain
the new set of transactions and some
random number and it put it in the hash
function that's it
that's what everybody does and they
start hashing if the output of this hash
function is some small number then we
say that they have found a solution to a
puzzle and we refer to this green thing
the random number as the puzzle solution
and we're going to refer to D here as a
difficulty so the smaller D is the
harder it is to find a a solution and
this is it that's what everybody does
that's it's extremely extremely simple
if you compare it to even the simplest
protocol that Alain was showing towards
then you know it's not true this is kind
of dirt easy right all you do is take
your new set of rows actions hash it
everybody just hash hash hash hash if
you find a solution great boom you found
a new block and you send it to everybody
and the only thing everybody does is
this so I'm gonna for now assume that
this hash function is a random Oracle
it's going to be very useful for
analysis so what this means is that the
best way you can find a solution to this
puzzle is through booth first search is
one extra subtlety I need to clarify in
this protocol and that is what happens
when I joined the network and I see one
chain like this is searching like this
which one should I be trying to extend
well it's very straightforward you do
the natural thing you go by the longest
chain here so if I see two different
chains I'm gonna always believe the
longest chain and I'm gonna always try
to extend from longest chain now this is
the whole protocol so me I want to join
to participate in this a protocol what
do I do I go and ask all the nodes out
there what is the longest chain now I
tell me what the longest thing there is
then I start mining I start trying to
confirm new transactions by putting in
puzzle solutions random numbers and try
to extend this chain that's it the whole
protocol
what what some guarantee that the
Genesis has not been pre- good years ago
yeah I need to have some guarantee that
like this random Oracle yes you know
this is a random Oracle you cannot
predict it yeah I need to buy so much
random Oracle right that it's a fresh
random or clear okay so the question now
it does this satisfy consistency right
that's what we want us so now le since
he's an organizer who didn't show up he
deserves being publicly shamed so let's
say that T now you know he gave this and
he was buying this house or bike from
Alessandra and he paid them least 50
bitcoins and then he decides I don't
want to pay right it would be much
better if I could get back my money so
what should he do at that you know to do
reverse this transaction very easy the
only thing you to do is to find some
other chain that's longer that kind of
like eclipse is this thing right
it goes back to here so let me rewind
the past to the past and try to get some
chain that's longer okay and then I can
trace this transaction I have my money
back I can spin it
so to do this he needs to find a longer
chain so how can you do it like a motors
claim what is that if this transaction
is actually sufficiently deep in this
chain then it should be safe in fact
what I came up to proposed was if there
are six transactions after it six blocks
after it that I'm fine it's really the
way you should think about this book
chain is you look at the current chain
the last six blocks are not really fully
confirmed yet but everything before
those six blocks are fine and together
intuition for why this is the case well
that if this transaction had been let's
say here it's a last one had just been
mined okay
so have this chain okay so here early
study Sandra something and this is the
last that has been mined
what's your attacker do to try to what
should really try to do well he will try
to now try to mind something else here
if he has let's say forty five percent
of the resources like forty nine for
simplicity now then with 50 percent
probability he's gonna find this thing
faster than the good guys extend this
right and then would another 50 percent
chance he's gonna be able to find this
thing right so with roughly 25 percent
chance he's gonna be ahead and what
happens when he's ahead that all the
good guys are like well this is where we
should be okay just intuition but if
it's like at words down here it's very
easy to to do this but if you're further
away then you need to be lucky sustain
is luckiness for a very long time and
that's going to be very likely that's
not very yeah total minus six is not
great but good enough so I don't know
what the probability of fraud is it visa
but maybe on the same order
so yeah I guess I'm not assumed that I
give the probability for the visa was
much smaller maybe they would you know
it's up to you maybe don't wait six
blocks you wait twenty okay okay so now
come out to show that it's much harder
yes yeah
then the acrylic was done also yes so
majority is a this is no this is the
most adversarial setting we go 36 yes
maybe it was who knows right okay so now
came out to show that just this this
approach doesn't quite work as I
mentioned Gary tell that is very nice
analysis shown actually that no attack
works in a setting where a sewer Delta
is one so this is you know this lockstep
model where whenever a certain message
is gets to everybody in the next round
and then sampling scheme Joker had a
white also deal with bigger Delta's but
now they're back to a setting where they
only didn't deal with all attacks
anymore
but only some certain classes of attacks
as I mention right now we know how to do
it for all attacks but before going to
formalizing what when
what we know about the security it will
be actually be helpful of defining this
more abstract notion of a blockchain
because it to kind of not only helped
analysis but this abstraction is is
useful if you want to use block chains
also to other things not just to set my
share application in fact there are
several works that try to use this more
advanced features also okay the first
thing is really just a third to
formalize this consistency notion that
Nakamoto envisioned which is a little
bit different than standard consistency
in state machine plication remember the
standard thing said that at any given
point my log is in reception or vice
versa there's no cutting of things so
here we have this abstraction that well
what we want to say is that if I look at
any two people's chains what the viewers
our longest chain if I get rid of the
last K blocks records a security
parameter then we should have
consistency very natural right so take
care to guys get rid of the last K
things
then except will exponentially they came
for built in K we should agree ability
over over the execution of the players
of randomness and good can run work oh
yeah
there's so the way we model it is
they're good guys and a single attacker
controls all the attackers there's a
single attacker
that's is trying to break consistency
okay I thought that there is consistency
again is subtle you need the spiritual
consistency we will discuss before let's
not do it again all right here's another
property as far as I know was first
introduced in the paper by Gretel and
it's a very useful property and it talks
about something will change qaulity so
chain quality considers when I look at
this chain does everybody has what
fraction of these blocks have been mined
by good players
so now when I did define it this way
what fact should be mined by good
players that's that's very tailored to
the reduction like a motor protocol but
you can actually give an abstract way of
defining it and intuitively you would
hope that if I'm controlling P fraction
of the computing power
I should contribute the P fraction of
blocks so chain quality measures
actually what fraction of the blocks
here or contributed by good nodes so I
said in idle scenario if a P fraction
good gosh you should get P you might not
get it you might have worse chain
quality on that okay
yes acceptability yeah sure with one
minus EPSA and the final thing is I
would want this chain to grow not too
fast and not too slow it should go to
steady rate it should roughly grow
proportional with like what Nova network
delay right so the network layer I'm
never send a message you guessed it
within Delta so roughly every Delta step
I should get a new block something like
that right that would be ideal to every
Delta step can you block so note that
this this chain go top is actually quite
interesting in its own right this kind
of says that it's a way to get a trusted
clock if I just look at the length to
the chain it's going to be ticking along
okay at the study pace and this is a
property it's only more advanced than
normal state machine application it's
actually this property is very useful
when you want to build things on top of
blockchain also because exactly this
thing I wanted to actually behave like a
clock I wanted to yes server
applications when you want to build new
protocols on top of Nakamoto
it's very useful to know that the chain
cannot just like suddenly run too fast
it can't be faster whatever Delta or
what did the study be really fast you
said you don't be too fast no I want it
to be something fixed so I can use the
other clock right no well it turns out
that you need to be like it can you
cannot hope to do better than one over
Delta
okay so just to make sure we understand
what these three things do let's just do
a very simple proof that these three
properties on drawn imply state machine
replication okay so how should I get a
state machine application for a block
shape well the natural thing is run this
blockchain protocol and then cut off the
last K blocks and output that that you
logged okay so that's the construction
of a state machine plication from a
blockchain why will it satisfy
consistency
well trivially by the definition of the
consistency from the blockchain
we said if I cut off the last egg then
we agree so that's trivial the
consistency really is trivial now why
aliveness it's a little bit more subtle
well darkness follows from the following
reason by chain growth I know that this
chain is going to continue growing right
will never stop boom boom boom boom boom
fetching quality I know that a certain
fraction of these nodes are going to be
by good guys good guys are going to
include all the all the transactions
they're here so therefore as long as I
have a good block it's gonna include
every transaction so whenever I hit that
I know it's gonna appear there so
therefore we have likeness okay to be
steady want to be steady and fast enough
yes definitely yeah yeah it cannot be
too slow it needs to be growing at a
certain reason with pace
yes
yeah so for for these two things if you
just want this you don't need an upper
bound on the chain growth you just need
a lower bound you want to be
sufficiently fast okay there are some
other applications I won't go into them
where it's actually very important to
have this upper bound also in order to
get this clock feature
yeah it should bowl is it should be
sometimes proportional to one over
network delay I'm trying to hide this
thing about people coming leaving too
much so right now with the way I'm going
to state things here is going to assume
that there is a certain number of people
that are there within some like constant
factor okay so you don't know who they
are within a factor of 100
okay so the chain is going to grow
sometimes let me not go into the there
are ways of changing the hardness and
the protocol does it it's like a little
bit more messy let me not okay it's not
not so before the break
let me just like mention what is secure
to this protocol is and then later on
I'm gonna do this castle if they don't
have to how to prove in this
the difference between an honest and no
known as the guy the the honest guys are
following this protocol in exactly the
way it was specified
no no skies in an attacker he can do
whatever he wants so whoever prepares a
book that's compliant with is honest and
an honest guy also needs to include all
the transaction here's if you if you
take the longest chain that you see you
prepare a block that contains than
you're honest yes an attacker isn't
whatever you do is something that's
different when the attacker controls the
certain fraction of players or a certain
fraction of computing power and he does
whatever he wants but I'm not concerned
about whether you can understand whether
you're honest or not the question is
whether being bad in able to do break
the protocol missing be complete will
check
okay yes in Bitcoin up the right now I'm
just talking about state machine
replication in Bitcoin you want to
enforce that other consistency properly
between transactions that you're not and
that the transactions are well formed
that you can always do that outside
state machine replication is kind of a
cleanup section you're saying I want a
list of a B and C okay I'm not going to
later on you can on top of that remove
things all right so what is that the
theorem so it actually turns out that
for every fractional players that's
smaller than 1/2 so up until on this
majority if you set the mining
difficulty correctly as a function of
the network delay the protocol is secure
so you get consistency you get some
chain quality and what is chain quality
is I'll get to the to it later
and the chain grows proportional to 1
over Delta like you want so what I mean
studied appropriately okay actually let
me just mention is chain : chain quality
this number here what you saw here this
formula it's not tight it's not exactly
what you want okay and I'll get back to
that in the second part we talked but
roughly it says something like if the
attacker controls one-third he can get
one half of the blocks and if it
controls less than one half then he can
get up to maybe 99 but there's still a
small fraction of good guess we get so
even up to 1/2 liveness gets worse the
more attacker has but you know it still
holds to slow things down for good guys
but and we'll discuss ways of like why
this is a problem with chain quality and
how to overcome it it's just to hint a
little bit of why we care about this
chain quality is actually going to be
for this game aesthetic reasons these
people are spending a lot of
computational effort they participate I
need to have some way of incentivizing
them and like a motor does that and
really in that case having good chain
quality is tightly related to whether
this particles gonna be incentive
compatible or not but we'll discuss that
later on but for now since we're just in
a distributed computing world we don't
really need to care about it we just
says as long as you have positive chain
called a you're fine
okay so what does it mean that this
mining difficulty is appropriately set
the important thing will be that these
blocks or mind slower than a network
delay so I need to chess set the
hardness and it is set in mining
difficulty to research the whole world
combined finds a block much on average
slower than Delta so it's going to be
with high probability action no sir
raw is the fraction the fraction that
perfectly controls so the attacker
controls half of the nodes that's the
block time which is this is what's
called the block time in a bit column
it's set to be ten minutes
so the mining difficulty is set so that
blocks are found every ten minutes okay
this needs to be a lot bigger than Delta
so you see like in practice people view
Delta's ten seconds I'm not sure where
that number actually comes from it was
based on some experiments I think from
the Decker what another paper and ten
minutes is much bigger than ten seconds
okay that's good
so how should it be set I'll show you
the formula after a break but before the
break
let me just like show a graph kind of
like security of the protocol how it
relates to how I set the block time okay
so let's see B the block time in terms
of network delay okay so the block time
is C times Delta okay so if C for
instance is 60 that's the scenario we
consider with Bitcoin today the block
time is ten minutes
natural is ten seconds that's ten
seconds times sixty right so this graph
says that when C the block time is sixty
you're up here and then it's secure
against the
9.50 7% attacker and and if you remember
whatever they can and whatever have this
forty nine point whatever it was this is
number is higher than what i claimed the
attack but when we looked at there was
they had some effector to mistake in
their calculation and if you actually do
it right this is the attack that they
provide and the attack actually is forty
nine point eight so the analysis seems
to be pretty tighter but between the
attack and and it becomes a little bit
less tight when you get closer to
network delay right presumably that's a
less interesting regime and in fact
there is this new very nice paper by
abby shallot and a few quarters that
have never better analysis here too and
I'll mention later on yeah yeah I guess
so a theorem is much more aggressive for
instance so theorem I forget what the
block time is they're setting it much
much more aggressively yeah sorry so I
guess maybe they're assuming the network
the latency is also not ten seconds but
I need it so this is a very this is a
very very pessimistic model this assumes
that attacker has full control of your
network and can delay message
arbitrary by Delta that's a very very
hot detective to do right and it also
shows that attacker is you know forty
nine point nine you know maybe don't
need to be there but maybe it's okay to
actually set yourself much lower and
then you can be at a much slower okay so
this is the the formula and we'll
discuss it after the break
[Applause]